walk to the southern district of new
york where the sentencing is being
carried out for the former british
socialite and convicted sex trafficker
gelaine maxwell sentencing in we're
hearing joe pike
yeah breaking news judge allison nathan
has sentenced gilay maxwell to 20 years
in prison with five years of supervised
release now gilead maxwell is 60 years
old she's already served
two years almost two years in custody
so she will be
approaching
her 80th birthday when she gets out of
prison now certainly prosecutors wanted
something far longer between 30 and 55
years and one victim of guillaine
maxwell told me going into court she
wanted ms maxwell to die in jail but one
thing that was particularly dramatic
that has happened in the last a half
hour is finally we have heard from ms
maxwell who is now of course a convicted
sex trafficker but through the many
years of this
legal saga has said almost nothing she
did in court apologize apologize for how
the impact of what has happened on
victims on young women whose lives are
of course
um diminished damage destroyed by
jeffrey epstein's abuse
she recognizes that she was close
friends with him and really regrets that
but she did not apologize for her own
role in jeffrey epstein's crimes because
of course she groomed a young girls as
young as 14 for him to sexually abuse
the reason of course gillay maxwell
hasn't probably apologized if she still
intends to appeal her sentence she's her
conviction sorry she still
attends to appeal that conviction on on
five different counts of uh sex
trafficking and that will follow in the
coming weeks and months as for now she
has been sentenced to 20 years in jail
and five years of post-sentence relief
so it is likely she will be in her late
70s almost 80 by the time she leaves
custody we should be hearing from some
of those victims who gave impact
statements in court we expect some of
them to speak outside court certainly
there were tears in the courtroom as
they explained
how that abuse had impacted their lives
one spoke about self-harm alcoholism uh
the inability to form a relationship the
fact she hadn't had children which she
pointed towards uh gillard maxwell and
jeffrey epstein as the reason for that
and she also said she'd attempted
suicide uh two times it's been a
emotional dramatic day at the court here
in new york city and it is not over
we'll be hearing from some of those
victims outside court and some lawyers
in the next hour
uh very busy afternoon for you joe thank
you very much more from joe pike a
little later on particularly when we
hear some of getting maxwell's victims
coming forward for those victim or those
victims statements that we will be
hearing outside of court we're going to
stay in the states now and go to
washington to speak to our u.s
correspondent mark stone because mark we
are seeing or hearing some very
compelling testimony uh regarding those
january 6 riots and the committee
investigating them what more are they
saying
yes it's all happening uh on this side
of the atlantic um today as surprise
hearing with this time yesterday we
weren't even aware that the january vi
committee would be holding a hearing
today but they then said that there
would be one uh we later discovered that
the uh the witness is cassidy hutchinson
not a household name uh but someone who
is at the very or was at the very heart
of the trump white house uh indeed at
the heart of the west wing her office
was just a few doors away from the oval
office she was the principal aide to
mark meadows who was donald trump's
chief of staff and she is continuing to
give evidence uh over the road from here
in in the capital about that day on
january the 6th 2021 when the capitol
building was stormed the background the
context of course
is at the extent to which donald trump
knew
that violence would take place
the extent to which he uh intended to
encourage
that violet violence and how much this
was all part of his plan to overturn the
2020 uh election among the highlights
briefly that we have heard in the last
20 minutes was an extraordinary
description of how donald trump grabbed
the steering wheel
of of the vehicle that he was in being
driven by the secret service because he
wanted to go down to the capitol
building and the secret service was
saying it was too dangerous to do that
we've also heard claims that he was
throwing plates across rooms
pulling um uh pulling tablecloths off
tables as well and that he was felt well
aware that people were going wanted to
hang mike pence the
the the vice president and that he did
nothing to stop that let's listen back
in
to send them home she wanted her dad to
tell them to go home peacefully and she
wanted to include
language that he necessarily wasn't on
board with at the time
you will hear more about this at our
later hearings but we have evidence of
many others
imploring donald trump and mark meadows
to take action here is some of that
evidence text messages sent to mark
meadows during the attack
this is a text message at 232 from laura
ingram
hey mark the president needs to tell
people in the capitol to go home
in the next message this is hurting all
of us
and then he's destroying his legacy and
playing into every stereotype we lose
all credibility against the blm antifa
crowd if things go south
the president's son don jr also urgently
contacted mark meadows
at 253 he wrote he's got to condemn this
[ __ ] asap the capitol police tweet is
not enough
as you will see these are just two of
the numerous examples of trump
supporters and allies urging the
president to tell his supporters to
leave the capitol
it would not have been hard for the
president to simply walk down to the
briefing room
a few feet down the hall from the oval
office
as norah o'donnell noted during an
interview with house republican leader
kevin mccarthy
where leader mccarthy said he believed
the attack was un-american
i want to quickly bring in kevin
mccarthy the house well as we continue
to hear this very compelling and
dramatic testimony from capitol hill
from washington i should say just wanted
to apologize for any uh language you may
have heard that you may have found uh
upsetting there back now to the
testimony i am i'm disappointed i'm sad
this is not what our country should look
like this is not who we are this is not
the first amendment this has to stop and
this has to stop now
leader mccarthy the president united
states has a briefing room steps from
the oval office it is the cameras are
hot 24 7 as you know why hasn't he
walked down and said that now
i convey to the president what i think
is best to do and i'm hopeful the
president will do it
republican house member mike gallagher
also
implored the president to call off the
attack
mr president
you have got to stop this you are the
only person who can call this
off
call it off
the election is over
call it off
this is bigger than you it's bigger than
any member of congress it is about the
united states of america
which is more important than any
politician
call it off
it's over
despite the fact that many people close
to donald trump were urging him to send
people home he did not do so until later
much later
at 4 17 p.m donald trump finally told
the rioters to go home
and that he loved them
here's a portion of the video president
trump recorded from the white house
we have to have peace
so go home
we love you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil
i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
but as we will show in even greater
detail in future hearings donald trump
was reluctant to put this message out
and he still could not bring himself to
condemn the attack
ms hutchinson has told us that too
um
i'm sure you've discussed it just to
elaborate if i hadn't already at that
point
i recall him
being reluctant to film the video on the
six i was not involved in
any of the logistics or the planning for
that video i just remember seeing the
video go out
and feeling a little shocked after it
went out
on the evening of january 6th and the
day after the president's family and his
senior staff and others
tried to encourage the president to
condemn the violence and commit to the
peaceful transition of power
at 3 31 pm on january 6 sean hannity of
fox news texted mark meadows
mr hannity said quote can he make a
statement i saw the tweet
ask people to leave the capitol
later that evening mr hannity sent
another text message to mark meadows
this time he shared a link to a tweet
that tweet reported that president
trump's cabinet secretaries were
considering invoking the 25th amendment
to remove president trump from office
as you can see on the screen
the 25th amendment to the constitution
creates a process for the transition of
power if a president is unfit or unable
to serve
25th amendment has never been used to
remove a president
but the committee has learned that after
the attack on the u.s capitol
this was being discussed by members of
president trump's cabinet
as a way of stripping the full power of
the presidency from donald trump
president trump's supporters were
worried
in addition to the tweet that he sent
mark meadows after the attack sean
hannity apparently spoke with president
trump
and warned him about what could happen
we understand that this text message
that sean hannity sent to kaylee mcaney
on january 7th shows what mr hannity
said to the president first
no more stolen election talk
second
impeachment and 25th amendment are real
many people will quit
miss hutchinson you told us that you
were hearing about discussions related
to the 25th amendment here's part of
what you said
mr pompeo reached out to have the
conversation with mr meadows in case he
hadn't heard the
discussions amongst cabinet secretaries
and from what i understand it was more
of a
this is what i'm hearing
i want you to be aware of it but i also
think it's worth putting on your radar
because you are the chief of staff
you're technically the boss of all the
cabinet secretaries and
you know if
conversations progress you should
be ready to take action on this like i'm
concerned
for
you and your positioning with this yeah
reach out to me if you have any
questions or like i could be helpful
with you at all
inside the white house the president's
advisors including members of his family
wanted him to deliver a speech to the
country
deputy white house counsel pat philbin
prepared the first draft of what would
be the president's remarks on national
healing
delivered by a pre-taped video on
january 7th
when he arrived at the white house on
the 7th mr philbin believed that more
needed to be said
so he sat down and started writing
he shared the draft with pat sipoloni
who also believed the president needed
to say more
mr sipoloni agreed with the content as
did eric hershman who reviewed the draft
the committee has learned that the
president did not agree with the
substance as drafted and resisted giving
a speech at all miss hutchinson do you
recall discussions about the president's
speech on january 7th
i do
let's listen ms hutchinson to what you
told us about that and about the process
of crafting those remarks
uh i learned from a conversation with
mark and
over here between him and white house
counsel and
um
eric hershman as well that
trump didn't necessarily think he needed
to do anything more on the seventh than
what he had
already done on the six
when he was
convinced to put out a video on the
seventh
he i understand that he had
a lot of opinions about what the context
of that announcement were to entail um i
had original drafts of the speech where
there were several lines that didn't
make it in there about
prosecuting the rioters or calling them
violent
he didn't want that in there he wanted
to put him there that he wanted to
potentially pardon them
um
it's just with the increased emphasis of
his mindset at the time which was
he didn't think that they did anything
wrong break from listening to that very
dramatic testimony coming out of
washington live to new york now after
glenn maxwell's been sentenced to 20
years in prison today was a towering day
for justice
as we saw gillian maxwell was sentenced
to 20 years in prison for the crimes she
committed against these survivors and so
many others
today showed us
that
individuals can be held accountable
irrespective of power and privilege
and today showed us
that the chorus of voices of these
survivors
prevailed and showed accountability
it's really a victorious day for justice
and on behalf of all the survivors we've
represented we want to thank the
prosecutors for their fierce and
relentless pursuit of justice here
we want to thank the judge for being
just and true and thoughtful
and we want to thank all of you for
never stopping and continuing to pursue
this story and make sure that their
voices were heard so now annie's going
to make a few statements how did the
survivors feel about maxwell's apology
uh i think they can probably speak to
that but um personally for me that was
not an apology she once again did not
acknowledge her crimes did not take
responsibility for them in any way so
that was really disappointing
may this sentence demonstrate that it is
never too late for the truth to come out
and never too late for there to be
accountability
if you're someone who's experienced
sexual abuse or exploitation
and did not feel safe to report those
crimes
or were not believed when you did or
were told that the perpetrators would
not be held accountable this is for you
there's still a lot of work to be done
on this issue
but in this fight we need to celebrate
the victories and today this is a big
victory
the truths about these crimes about
child sexual abuse and exploitation are
deeply uncomfortable they happen more
frequently than we want to acknowledge
and often perpetrators as we saw in this
case are not strangers and vans they're
the people that live in our communities
and they're people often in positions of
power
maxwell and epstein were predators who
were able to use that power and
privilege
to harm countless individuals and for
far too long the institutions that
should be protecting the public were
instead protecting them
and i still hope that we find out more
about how that was allowed to occur
we know that historically though that
this has happened in many organizations
and many institutions that predators are
protected
um
in you know in churches in political
groups in the foster care system and so
i just hope that this sentence can be
another sign that voices are coming
together and saying no more
if you commit these crimes you will be
punished if you facilitate these crimes
you will be punished if you are a
bystander that looks the other way you
will not be allowed to continue to hold
a position of power
it's easy to focus on the darkness in
the case like this
but i also think it's important to
highlight all the people that have
worked so hard to bring the truth to
light
and i want to start
by expressing my gratitude and
appreciation for my sister maria farmer
who reported these crimes
over decades ago and has so bravely
continued to try and bring attention and
fight for justice in this case
for all for the other women who sport
who spoke in the courtroom
i am so grateful
for the other survivor sisters that i've
met on this journey who have worked so
hard to make this happen
i am incredibly grateful this would not
have happened without so many voices
coming together
i am so incredibly grateful for my team
of attorneys most especially sigrid
mccauley who has gone above and beyond
at every step of the way to support us
and encourage us that this could happen
for brad edwards and his team
for
the for the media who were you know
really i think continued to tell the
story and try and bring attention to
this case
to uh the agents who worked so hard and
dedicated themselves these last few
years to the maxwell case
into the fierce team of prosecutors who
took a chance to bring this to trial
and to show that she could be held
accountable for this heinous heinous
scheme
so how did you feel speaking in court
annie how do you feel
[Music]
it actually felt very powerful to
finally have a chance to speak and and
you know have my voice on the record uh
and say the things that i wanted to say
about how her crimes have impacted the
impact of myself and the people that
that i know and care about honey how did
you feel listening to her in court uh
just i'll just say one more thing that
yeah her her statement felt like a very
hollow apology to me and she did not
take responsibility for the crimes that
she committed and it felt like once more
her trying to do something to benefit
her
and not at all about the harm that she
had caused it's 20 years this is annie
farmer who is a victim certainly was a
victim of galaine maxwell and jeffrey
epstein reacting to the news there that
uh maxwell just in the last few minutes
or so has been sentenced to 20 years in
prison for helping jeffrey epstein
sexually abused teenage girls
at a court in new york we'd like to as a
testimony continues we want to bring in
uh lisa bloom now lisa joining us live
from los angeles she's a lawyer lisa you
uh represented some of eight i believe
jeffrey epstein's victims uh not annie
farmer but i could see you listening to
to annie's speech there you you're
nodding in agreement i mean it's an
emotional day isn't it for everyone
who's been involved in this
extraordinary uh court case and the many
years it's taken to to get justice but
has justice been done
i think justice has been done and you're
right i'm getting choked up on behalf of
my clients who struggled for years to
get justice and ultimately we did
against the jeffrey epstein compensation
fund but to see
elaine maxwell now sentenced to 20 years
in prison that is a long prison term
it's just a little bit longer than the
guidelines i think the judge made a very
good and wise decision and elaine is
going to have a lot of time to think
about the pain and the injuries that she
caused
she'll be approaching her 80th birthday
when she is released from a u.s federal
uh jail and we actually heard what the
court heard from
delaney maxwell herself the first time
we've actually heard from her really
apologizing saying the greatest regret
of her life was was meeting epstein in
the first place but annie farmer saying
there that those words rank hollow that
they meant nothing to her what do you
think
i agree and i listened very carefully
and these words were obviously written
by her attorneys because she apologizes
for the pain she says she's sorry to
hear the pain that so many victims
testified to today but she doesn't
apologize for what she did she doesn't
express remorse for the choices that she
made that led her being convicted of
multiple felonies and now 20 years
behind bars i don't think she has any
remorse and that's why she didn't
express any
and
again annie talked about no more
this never being allowed to happen again
of course we talked about her
people with vast wealth and vast
powerful connections well lisa what do
you think the legacy of this of this uh
whole episode will be
do you think
you know a lot of people are saying that
me too is over every time there's a bump
in the road and this case is a great
illustration of the fact that me too is
just beginning that survivors of sexual
abuse are standing up and speaking out
every day i represent dozens and dozens
of them now and even when someone is
wealthy and powerful if victims are
willing to come forward if advocates are
willing to fight for them they can
ultimately get justice
we have to leave it there i'm afraid
lisa fernando thank you very much lisa
bloom uh joining us there regarding the
sentencing that's just come in of gelane
maxwell back to washington now the
committee investigating the january vi
riots on capitol hill is holding its
latest hearing let's tune in
without objection
the committed stands are joined
[Applause]
plenty more coming up the top of the
hour from those capital rights here
hearings which are taking place in
washington dc right now we've had some
very powerful testimonies some more
analysis for you coming up at the top of
the hour here on sky news
[Music]
it is eight o'clock you are watching sky
news tonight our top story galaine
maxwell is sentenced to 20 years for sex
trafficking a judge tells jeffrey
epstein's former partner that no one is
above the law as she is jailed for
helping him abuse teenage girls
today showed us
that
individuals can be held accountable
irrespective of power and privilege
the hearing into the january 6 riots is
told president trump tried to take the
seized control of his official car when
he was told he couldn't go to the
capitol
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
also tonight hope's fade of finding
survivors from the attack on the
ukrainian shopping center hit by a
russian missile
as nato leaders meet in madrid turkey
ends its opposition to finland and
sweden joining the alliance
i don't think it will come to that and
clearly we're working
very hard to make sure that we confine
this to
to ukraine
the met police is put into special
measures after a string of failures
[Applause]
[Music]
applause from the snp as nicola sturgeon
sets out a plan to hold a vote on
scottish independence next year
and a snapshot of an aging and growing
population we're going to take you
through the findings of the latest
census
[Music]
very good evening to you guys maxwell
has been sentenced to 20 years in jail
for her part in recruiting teenagers who
are abused by the disgrace financier
jeffrey epstein maxwell was convicted of
five charges of sex trafficking and
grooming girls in december of last year
well let's take you now straight outside
the court in new york we're hearing
victim impact statements of being read
and this
this is bobby sternheim the
lawyer for
elaine maxwell outraged
by her situation
and that is all i have to say so thank
you
aguilan's decision to speak in court
i thought her statement was moving
and on point
and as everyone should know
that anybody who is appealing their
sentence
has the right to maintain the record
and the issues on appeal
[Music]
kevin you're speaking yes
and
so just uh to say that we have nothing
and to add to the very heartfelt
statement that gilen gave in court
and nothing to add to the comments that
she made
about the victims
and her
sincere hope
that the trial her conviction and this
sentencing will allow the victims some
closure
and just to echo what bobby sternheim
has said uh guilan will be exercising
her right to appeal
her conviction and sentence and we
the family will be
solidly behind her all the way thank you
very much
[Laughter]
well as you can imagine some pretty
chaotic scenes outside the court in new
york we were just hearing from bobby
sternheim the lawyer of the defendant
galen maxwell and her brother we believe
saying that she will exercise her right
to appeal after being sentenced to 20
years in prison for helping geoffrey
epstein sexually abuse teenage girls
bobby stern i'm also going on to say
uh that um
her statement that she said in court we
actually heard from delane maxwell that
it was moving and on point something
that certainly has um
not been agreed to by many of her
victims who have been speaking as well
in court we are expecting actually
plenty more victim impact statements
coming through uh in new york and as
soon as we get them we will bring them
to you live another live developing
story that's happening right now are the
hearings into the capital riots which
happened on january 6th last year
they're ongoing in washington right now
we've been hearing that president trump
trying to take control of his official
car when he was told that he couldn't go
to the capitol his former chief of staff
has been describing what's been
happening so let's listen in again to
what's happening right now in uh
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president take me up to
the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
let's bring in our u.s correspondent
mark stone joins us now live from
washington what uh have you what do you
make of what's happened so far mark
it's pretty remarkable stuff it has in
fact just concluded for the day the
woman you saw there is cassidy
hutchinson not a household name but
someone who was at the very heart of the
trump white house she was okay mark
we're just going to interrupt you for
two minutes so we're having a slight
problem with your microphone i'm not
sure whether you can see it or not
doesn't appear to be uh on your uh lapel
but if you could put that on for us that
would be absolutely great uh in the
meantime let's let me get you up to date
with what
we've been hearing um cassidy hutchinson
has been speaking now cassie hutchinson
is certainly not a household name she's
not somebody uh that you may have heard
of before she's 25 year old summer
intern who was working uh throughout
that fateful day january the sixth last
year on capitol hill she was the intern
to us a top aide mark meadows who's the
chief of staff uh to president trump at
the time and she had some pretty
compelling things to say regarding uh
what the crowds were chanting at one
point the crowds are chanting for the
vice president mike pence to be hung of
course you can imagine that's incredibly
inflammatory and she had some very
compelling things to say on the back of
that mark i pleased to say that your
microphone problem has been resolved uh
what did you make of what she had to say
it has my fault sorry i forgot to put it
on uh yeah so let me give you the
context of what was being discussed
today and you'll remember january the
6th 2021 uh the storming of the capitol
building here in washington dc
about an hour or two before that
happened donald trump was giving a
speech in front of the white house
between the white house and the cat and
the washington monument to a huge group
of people who over the course of the
previous couple of weeks had been told
to come to washington because they were
going to try on that day to stop the
handover of power from president trump
to president biden because the trump
presidency had been insisting for months
since the election had taken place that
it had been stolen
now what we heard from cassidy
hutchinson just then was a description
of what happened after that speech when
donald trump wanted to go
from where he was in front of the white
house in a vehicle to the capitol and
march with the protesters it was deemed
not safe to do so because there were so
many protesters and so many of them were
armed uh he had already told his staff i
don't care that they're armed they're
not they're not here to cause any harm
to me
and he wanted more protesters to be
allowed into the secure zone outside the
white house when he was then told that
he couldn't go to the capitol to the
capitol building that is when um he is
alleged to have tried to grab the tried
to grab the steering wheel of the
vehicle he was in and he was told to
take his hand off the steering wheel he
then allegedly put his hand around the
neck of the person who told him to take
his hand off the steering wheel quite
extraordinary uh stuff from cassidy
hutchinson who as i say was at the very
heart of the of the trump white house
and has is one of many many witnesses
who have now come forward to explain
what was happening not just on j on
january the sixth but in the the weeks
and months prior to that during which
time as i say donald trump and those
around him were alleging against all
fact
that the election
had been stolen the significance now of
course of all this is that donald trump
has said he may run for the presidency
again in 2024. he's still in the spell
the trumpism spell still holds huge
weight over over large parts of uh of
the electorate in the united states
something like 70 percent of republicans
believe the claim that the election was
stolen and so what this committee is
trying to do
is to demonstrate to the american public
that donald trump is a fraud is corrupt
tried to steal the election a genuine
election back for himself and that he
could well do it again now this election
this uh committee yes most of the
committee members are democrats but most
of those giving evidence have been
republicans loyal republicans once to
donald trump but no longer it's
compelling stuff
it is indeed mark for now thank you very
much our u.s correspondent mark stone
live in washington for us and of course
we're going to bring you all the latest
on those hearings here on sky news if
you'd like to watch the testimony live
you can do so by scanning the qr code on
your screen right now or by visiting the
sky news app or website
we're going to carry on with u.s
coverage for you now taking you live
back to new york where in the last half
an hour or so galen maxwell has just
been sentenced to 20 years for sex
trafficking as sky correspondent joe
pike as you see has uh been covering the
story for us all day he's outside the
court in new york for us right now and
we're hearing from a whole host of
people in the last few minutes hearing
from gilley maxwell's lawyer and also
her siblings
yeah the siblings i tried to speak to
kevin maxwell one of guillermo maxwell's
brothers didn't want to
say much and certainly bobby sternheim
her lead lawyer who's been a big figure
throughout this
case she seemed a little bit frustrated
she knows her clients in a bit of a
difficult
situation because she yes apologized in
court when she made this dramatic
statement when she took the stand
finally to
acknowledge the cover the courage of the
women who'd been
victims of her and jeffrey epstein she
said sorry but not for her own actions
the reason for that is that she intends
to appeal and therefore bobby sternheim
i think realizes there's a tricky
situation after the sentence she wants
to appeal some legal experts say it
would be very difficult to win that but
by the point that that legal avenue has
been uh gone down has been finished with
well gideon maxwell's still left with a
20-year
prison term she's 60 years old she's
already been in custody for nearly two
years so we're talking about her getting
out of custody in her late 70s and then
having five years of supervised
release release
there were a couple of dramatic moments
before gilead maxwell spoke in court and
those were when women who whose lives
have been really damaged uh by her abuse
got their chance finally to explain the
impact it had on them a number of women
were in tears talking about how they've
been unable to form relationships have
children they've said it into alcoholism
in one case
one victim saying that she'd attempted
suicide twice because
gila maxwell when she was a very young
girl
trafficked her uh groomed her for
jeffrey epstein to sexually abuse now
this case is seemingly over for now
apart from the appeal but let's also be
clear that this pair partners in crime
epstein and maxwell did not act alone
talking to some of the key lawyers in
this case representing victims they
point to people they
say were co-conspirators
and therefore it will be interesting to
see where the u.s government where
prosecutors go next will there be
more trials more people held to account
for their actions in the 90s and the
early 2000s where some estimate more
than 160 women and girls were abused by
jeffrey epstein certainly nothing will
be
as important major as or as dramatic as
gilley maxwell's trial and sentencing
because of the key role she played at
the heart of that criminal enterprise
she's now been sentenced to 20 years
followed by five years
of supervised release she will spend the
rest of her life almost
in a custody and talking to some victims
like annie farmer today they think that
is enough
okay joe for now thank you joe pike live
in new york for us on the golaim maxwell
sentencing well we've got more
developing news for you this evening
turkey has ended its opposition to
finland and sweden joining nato that's
been the very latest now our security
and defense editor deborah haynes joins
us now uh live from madrid of course
you've been there all day for us deborah
and is this what they were hoping to be
able to announce as they try and show a
united front against russia
it certainly is uh there was sort of a
brewing sense that something was coming
over the course of of this afternoon
there were talks this afternoon between
the leaders of turkey uh sweden and
finland as well as the nato secretary
general they were only supposed to last
about 90 minutes but they extended on
into the evening and as soon as that
happened i was getting messages saying
that something's coming uh expect
something soon keep your eyes open
keep your ears
listening for any news and certainly
that news came it was news that allies
frankly hadn't been daring to hope would
happen in time for the summit given the
strength of turkey's opposition in
particular to sweden uh in terms of its
belief that sweden has been supporting
kurdish militias that ankara views as
terrorists and president erdogan came
here to madrid
on this day when the summit is starting
and has clearly
managed to secure sufficient assurances
from sweden in particular that
its concerns with regards to turkish
militias